[Musique]
voici le premier entrepôt volant
d'amazon des drones y récupère des colis
qui seront livrés chez vous en moins de
30 minutes
il ne s'agit pas de canular enfin pas
tout à fait amazon détient déjà le
brevet qui pourrait lui permettre de
réaliser cela
pour vous le fondateur d'amazon est
prête à tout
jeff bezos ce est obsédé par la
satisfaction des consommateurs
il a créé une multitude de gadgets qui
lui permettent de vous suivre pas à pas
de vous voir et de vous entendre il a
même trouvé une façon de briser votre
solitude
entre coistia news awards creed 2 est
maintenant il a dépensé des fortunes
pour mettre au point des robots qui
manipulent et livre vos achats en un
temps record amazon est en train de
redéfinir les habitudes des
consommateurs à la grandeur du monde
mais quelle est la face cachée de ses
prouesses ici au canada le danger c'est
vraiment l'étendue du monopole et la
profondeur qu'elle est en train de
prendre toutes les facettes d'un ami qui
frappe vraiment c'est que amazon réussi
à payer de l'impôt sur une toute petite
partie de fines revenus totaux en
donnant du stand à au kehrweg doing what
they do
[Musique]
pour voir l'envers du sourire d'amazon
nous sommes allés à leur rencontre
d'entrepreneurs qui ont fait le grand
saut sur la place de marché
peut plus aujourd'hui dans mon usine à
québec les bottes les souliers
jonathan leclercq est un passionné de la
chaussure il est co propriétaire du
fabricant martineau nos produits sont
100 % canadien tout est fait ici dans l'
usine en une soixantaine de personnes
qui travaillent à toutes les étapes
jonathan vend ses créations dans sa
boutique du vieux québec et donc
plusieurs magasins du canada et du nord
des états unis
mais ça ne lui suffit pas une des
consommatrices comme vous bientôt 300
millions à travers les états-unis pijper
capable d'aller les rencontrer en parle
dans quelques semaines jonathan va
lancer ses mocassins sur amazon amazon
c'est une vitre c'est une énorme vitrine
pour un homme presque incalculable de
consommateurs
amazon et la place de marché la plus
populaire au monde auprès des
consommateurs 200 millions d'abonnés
prime payant
3500 nouveaux vendeurs chaque jour
475 milliards de dollars de ventes en
2020 je suis inquiet aux deux extrémités
ou de pouvoir de résultat ou d'en avoir
trop de prêts à être capable de soutenir
la demande
sur amazon tout est possible
dimanche sur la fin j'ai fait une demi
session cégep puis
pour moi tu tombais sur le modèle
d'affaires qui amazon et ça m'a vraiment
ce qu'est la parenthèse ça fait que le
sens à mes yeux love panorama
marcoule roux est un des nombreux
enfants prodiges d'amazon un masque
respiratoire
c'est le premier produit qu'il a mise en
vente
j'ai en ce sens 2016 la première journée
que j'étais
là et j'ai fait pas celui de vente
première journée l'année dernière marco
a vendu pour 1,6 million de dollars de
masques c'est mon grain de plus puissant
ça c'est un ordre marque au vent
maintenant une trentaine de produits il
les fait fabriquer en chine il n'a pas
d'entrepôt à part son cabanon et pas
d'employer toutes les tâches ingrates
amazon les faits pour lui on envoie nos
stocks c'est tout le week-end les pma
ils font les remboursements les sur sa
clientèle
comme 92% des vendeurs sur amazon
marcoux utilisent le service fbi a full
field by amazon en france est expédiée
par amazon un service qui n'est pas
donné chaque fois qu'on fait une vente
amazon spray 15% ses missions
ensuite les frères marc et et les frais
de livraison les frais d'entreposage
l'an dernier 47 % du montant des ventes
de marco s'est retrouvé dans les poches
d'amazon c'est sûr que oui amazon sont
les grands gagnants de toute somme il
faut le voir
le côté positif c'est que
profit offrir au vendeur une
infrastructure qu'aucune autre place de
marché en ligne n'est capable de
concurrencer ça a été l'un des traits de
génie de jeff les sauces je remercie d
amazon
l'entrepreneur mike white celle de nos
hôtels au québec des tests amazon autant
que marco leroux la vénère de compte une
vingtaine wayne law to increase de
l'e-business
l'histoire de mike représente bien celle
de nombreux wanda
[Musique]
aux etats unis un sous-comité du
gouvernement vient de mener une enquête
sur les pratiques anti concurrentielles
des gaffes les google apps au facebook
et amazon il a été mis en lumière qu
amazon app usé de sa position dominante
pour maltraiter ses vendeurs
pour mike les choses avaient pourtant
bien commencé
il y a dix ans il a lancé ses produits
pour enfants sur amazon des trousses
pour fabriquer des brillants à lèvres
des savants et des banques de bain
prenez note du mot bombe nous allons y
revenir sur
les affaires de mike vont trop bien
amazon veut qu'il devienne fournisseurs
ou timmins ils se croient meilleurs pros
aract nb sales draps
il faut savoir qu amazon est un géant à
deux têtes elle est l'opératrice de la
place de marché où les vendeurs comme
mike affichent leurs produits mais elle
est aussi un détaillant elle vend ses
propres produits ou des produits
qu'elles achètent en gros à des
fournisseurs faisant directement
concurrence aux autres vendeurs le prof
une famille heureuse was under
mike ne veut pas qu amazon vente s'est
produit à rabais pour ne pas nuire aux
boutiques quillivant aussi ils refusent
de devenir fournisseur pourtant peu de
temps après un long run by amazon mark
robinson
amazon amazon a contourné mike et
s'approvisionnent directement chez son
distributeur américain amazon
silk épil whitney
c'est la catastrophe
olsen ce drop out the fight et 10%
pour couronner le tout mike perd le
contrôle de sa fiche produit
pendant des semaines mike multiplient
les appels chez amazon mais il n'arrive
à rien
une lettre adressée à jeff bezos
le problème c'est que mike ne veut pas
qu amazon vente s'est produit
à cette
relation
amazon n'a pas résolu le problème c'est
mike qui a convaincu son distributeur de
cesser de vendre ses produits à amazon
mike a gagné la première manche mais il
n'est pas au bout de ses peines
c'est le temps de célébrer pour jonathan
leclercq
aujourd'hui on expédie nos premiers
produits chez amazon tantôt ils viennent
chercher ça on a tout misé sur palettes
c'est reparti celle ci
devrait
les multiples démarches administratives
imposées par amazon depuis deux mois
sont enfin terminés on avait des
partenaires cloud compute côté relation
avec amazon et à chaque fois j'étais
content d'avoir
besoin c'est le consultant cassiopée
morin qui s'occupe du dossier de
jonathan malgré le fait qu'on a réussi
arrive dans les mains on camara vendre
des armes qui encore aujourd'hui vont
peut-être retarder certains volets du
projet cassiopée travail pour nos
batailles une des nombreuses entreprises
qui se sont développés pour aider les
vendeurs à naviguer dans la jungle
amazon c'est marco l'euro de congédier
marco leroux a senti le filon il a écrit
un livre est fondé lui aussi une
entreprise de coaching en offre des
forfaits complets aux 5000 dollars
canadiens marco est formel on le
s'improvise pas vendeur sur amazon favon
les reins solides
pour pourvoir sur amazon parce que sinon
on peut vraiment s'arracher les cheveux
les consultants amazon sont devenues
nécessaires à cause des défaillances du
service aux vendeurs affreux sur sa
clientèle amazon est vraiment ces jeunes
comme quoi c'est
leur faiblesse et un tapis rouge pour
les consommateurs sally peut-être un
petit peu moins pour les marchands
jérôme payet et money cash back oscars
sont les propriétaires de la marque de
jouets ghimpu il vente sur amazon mais
aussi sur est si une autre plateforme de
vente en ligne c'est beaucoup plus
simple en général
de faire affaire comme marchand avec
ainsi que amazon
le problème qui constitue la hantise de
tous les vendeurs c'est la suspension de
la fiche produit
soupçons qu'on respecte pas la loi ils
peuvent suspendre la fiche produit
complet et la baisse on dépense d'amazon
pour lui c'est ce qui est arrivé à
jérôme et monica en septembre 2019 alors
que leurs jouets sont en vente depuis
huit mois amazon exigent un certificat
de sécurité qui n'a jamais été exigé
auparavant un certificat qui est long à
obtenir
parfois le motif des suspensions est
complètement farfelu de son
rapport à
[Musique]
ce matin ça veut dire matières
dangereuses
mike van pourtant des produits pour le
bain
[Musique]
pour les algorithmes d'amazon une bombe
c'est une bande même si elle est
fabriquée de fécule de maïs
sunday
mais pas sur amazon
encore une fois mike a perdu beaucoup
d'argent mais il est resté sur amazon
une des conclusions de la récente
enquête américaine et kamaz on est
devenu quasi incontournable
amazon accapare presque 40% des ventes
en ligne aux états unis contre 5 %
seulement pour voir mike son principal
compétiteur si je me lance une marque à
j'ai presque pas le choix au moins faire
un bout sur la zone karl boutet est un
expert en stratégie de commerce de
détail il observe les comportements
d'amazon depuis dix ans la façon que je
pense qu'ils abusent le plus présent est
avec la remarque privé de prendre les
atouts de la partenaire qui vendent
leurs plateformes d'en tirer avantage
amazon aurait elle-même lancé plus de
400 marques de produits dont la
populaire amazon bx à plusieurs reprises
elle a été accusée de profiter des
informations privilégiées dont elle
dispose sur ses vendeurs pour reproduire
leurs produits les plus rentables
les soins pic de
0,6 en octobre 2020 pic design se rend
compte qu amazon vend un produit très
semblables aux siennes
son propriétaire riposte avec une vidéo
satirique
impossible de prouver que des données
privilégiés ont été utilisés dans ce cas
ci mais pas de doute sur la source
d'inspiration même nom même design logo
presque identique
évidemment le prix n'est pas le même 22
dollars contre 79 ils vont dire que
quand je serai là produit que la
consommatrice le consommateur veut en
utilisant leurs pulsions de pouvoir pour
la rentrée - de façon moins cher mais ça
fait que ça étoffe ce qui amène les
nouvelles idées ou si la vidéo de piques
design est devenue virale un coup de
publicité incroyable pour la compagnie
un peu moins pour amazon et
toutes les histoires ne se termine pas
aussi bien
interpellé par les élus américains jeff
bezos ce n'a pas nié que des
informations privilégiées avait pu être
utilisées
c'est dans ce monde où la compétition
est féroce et souvent déloyale que
jonathan s'apprête à sauter protesté
demandant de voir comment ça va
fonctionner qu'est ce que ça vient
des millions de consommateurs
découvriront bientôt les mocassins de
jonathan des consommateurs gâtés par
l'écosystème à maison des fois ce qui
est très efficace et les consommateurs
qui veulent en profiter de ce système
commandé 10 chandail pour un retourné 9
déclaré faussement qu'un article n'a pas
été livrée pour en obtenir un deuxième
gratuitement certains consommateurs sont
vraiment détestable
pensez vous que je me commandait un bon
mocassins loi je retournais une vieille
paire de godasses amazon passé louche
frais remboursés j'ai entendu dire que
ça pourrait fonctionner je le fais
comment résister à un tel défi on a
commandé une paire de mocassins et on
s'est mis à la recherche d'une paire de
godasses on vous en donne des nouvelles
désolé jonathan
[Musique]
bonjour tout le monde on est à la mi
juillet en plein milieu de l'été et ça
fait quelques semaines que nos bacs à
sel sont en vente sur amazon voyez la
semaine passée on a vendu cette part
c'est au départ qu'il répond à nos
attentes
un peu là mais c'est ça qu'on
s'attendait ont très hâte de voir la
progression des ventes qui va suivre
une des paire de mocassins vendus par
jonathan leclercq et dans cette boîte
qu'on vient de nous livrer on va faire
un test est il vrai qu'on peut retourner
n'importe quoi chez amazon et se faire
rembourser par le vendeur on met dans la
boîte une vieille paire de mocassins
usagers qu'on a payé 3 dollars à la
place des mots qu'assad jonathan qui
valent 75 dollars et on expédie le tout
chez amazon en demandant un
remboursement à suivre
[Musique]
avant d'aller plus loin regardons
comment le fondateur d'amazon a bâti son
empire mais capacité de l'entreprise à
livrer du revenu livrer une satisfaction
clientèle
on en perd ses nuits sans mac elle coupe
la société
jeff bezos sa faune des amazones en 1994
dans le garage de sa maison située en
banlieue de seattle dans l'état de
washington
27 ans plus tard bge hausse est l'homme
le plus riche est l'un des plus
puissants au monde comme stratège
d'affaires comme visionnaire d'affaires
des revenus de
386 milliards de dollars américains en
la moitié de ces revenus provient de la
vente des produits qu amazon vend elle
même sur la plateforme le reste provient
des frais payés par les vendeurs des
services info nuages et des abonnements
de la publicité et des magasins
traditionnels
mais la clé de voûte du succès d'amazon
ce n'est pas sa diversification
c'est la patience de ses actionnaires
d'abc quand on investit en compagnie
c'est pour avoir des retours en
dividendes dont aux places qu'on veut on
veut que la compagnie nous retourne de
l'argent mais jeff bezos très tôt a pu
convaincre les investisseurs que c'était
à leur détriment de façon qu'ils
devaient s'attendre à ce que lui
investit continuellement les profits ça
semble aller de soi aujourd'hui mais
c'était révolutionnaire
il y avait un temps
au cours des dix premières années amazon
accumule des pertes qui totalise des
milliards de dollars
amazon se permet de vendre des produits
et des services à terre tu en
investissant massivement dans son
développement elle prend une longueur
d'avancé qui semble aujourd'hui
insurmontables
on fait face à un almagro
qui a pas de stratégie d'affaires qui
vont permettre d'aller directement face
à face à camara ou même stewart benz des
cosco
réinvestir la majeure partie de ses
profits comporte un autre avantage
l'équation est vraiment faim - ont fait
des profits moins on paye nos impôts
nous avons demandé à la fiscaliste
brigitte alepin d'analyser les états
financiers d'amazon ce qui frappe
vraiment c'est que amazon réussi à payer
plein pot sur une toute petite partie de
ses revenus totaux durand fait vingt
premières années d'opération
entre 1995 et 2000 14 pendant qu amazon
établi sa dominance elle génère 409
milliards de dollars de revenus et son
bénéfice net avant impôts et 2,4
milliards seulement l'équivalent de 1%
de ses revenus nous avons aussi demandé
à brigitte alpes est d'analyser les
états financiers de deux des concurrents
d'amazon on s'aperçoit que wang et cosco
ont une partie de leur revenu total qui
devient imposables qui beaucoup plus
élevé que amazon de 1995 à 2014 le
bénéfice net avant impôts de wal mart
représentait
5,3 pour cent ses revenus totaux et
celui de cosco 2,8 pour cent mais ça
s'arrête pas là c'est que sur ce petit
bénéfice
amazon réussi à payer beaucoup moins
d'impôts que ses concurrents wal mart et
cosco ses concurrents dans le monde
tangible
si on regarde amazon de ses débuts à
2020 une période de 26 ans on découvre
que sur son petit bénéfice elle a payé
9,8 pour cent d'impôt pendant la même
période
wal mart et costco paient respectivement
31,8 % et 30 % d'impôts
c'est énorme
lorsqu'on constate que une société pète
trois fois moins d'impôts que ses
concurrents on peut se laisser aller à
imaginer qu est-ce qui aurait pu faire
les concurrents ces mêmes l'industrie
dans son ensemble s'est elle avait été
imposée à un niveau d'imposition qui est
égal ou similaires un des facteurs qui
expliquent le faible ratio d'impôts
payés par amazon et qu'elle opère dans
le cyberespace et non dans des magasins
physiques
ça permet à amazon de pouvoir
manipuler son revenu puis l'établir dans
les juridictions où est ce que les taux
d'imposition sont les plus faibles alors
que warm heart et cosco sont obligés de
payer un certain degré d'un certain
niveau d'impôts dans chacun des pays où
est ce que les magasins sont installés
amazon paie de l'impôt canada mais a
refusé de nous dire combien par courriel
pour expliquer son faible ratio d'impôts
payés elle nous a écrit les
investissements de capitaux la
rémunération à base d'actions et les
crédits d'impôts au titre de la
recherche et du développement sont
prises en compte dans le calcul de
l'impôt sur le revenu d'amazon aux états
unis ce qui réduit nos obligations
fiscales et notre taux d'imposition
effectif
bryant est un des consultants amazon les
plus reconnus au canada
dave est aussi vendeur sur amazon et ce
qui l'inquiète particulièrement c'est la
présence grandissante des vendeurs
chinois sur la plateforme
nous avons commandé une étude à la firme
de consultants de dez bryant pour
comparer les pourcentages de vendeurs
chinois et canadiens sur amazon.ca la
plateforme canadienne d'amazon
seulement 16% des vendeurs des produits
les plus vendus sur amazon.ca sont
canadiens soixante deux pour cent sont
basés en chine la chine est
le pays ennemi d'hier devant de ramadan
tous les fournisseurs qui s'ils veulent
ou s'ils ouvrent les yeux et
commence à vendre leurs produits sur la
patron d'amazon ce qu'on pourrait pas
battre leurs prix ces deux fournisseurs
ça pourrait devenir la nouvelle tendance
les manufacturiers chinois qui contourne
les vendeurs canadiens pour vendre
directement sur amazon heureusement pas
obéi
un câble
ces intermédiaires des vendeurs comme
marco même s'ils vendent des produits
fabriqués en chine ont un tel impact
positif sur l'économie canadienne moi je
paie mes impôts ici l'eau si quelqu'un
achète mes produits sur amazon même les
imposons pas d'ici
ce qui n'est pas le cas des vendeurs
chinois qu amazon courtisent sans
relâche toiture
amazon.ca risque d'être d'année en année
de plus en plus chinoise est de moins en
moins canadienne
amazon a bouleversé l'ordre mondial du
commerce de détail il appartient
maintenant aux consommateurs d'en tirer
le meilleur sans provoquer le pire
qu'est-ce qu'elle consommateurs qui
magasinent sur amazon qu'est-ce qui doit
réaliser qu'ils pensent plus loin que
son ca transaction qu'est-ce que cet
achat la pour cause et autour de moi
qu'on parle d'eux des impacts fiscaux
les impacts de redistribution de
richesses et si ces choses là qu'on voit
pas quand la boîte brunarie
[Musique]
claude larose jeune retraité à deux
jouets préférés sa luxueuse voiture
électrique et son enceinte échos
d'amazon alex à
[Musique]
ses côtés pratico pratique si on veut de
la technologie car j'adore ça allait
mais cuisine
fermée buffet hockey a juste mon
thermostat à 20 degrés ok alexa peut
envoyer vos commandes à des milliers
d'appareils wifi grâce à l amazone vous
entend et avec ces appareils de sécurité
au ring amazon vous voit
france aura
bientôt une caméra drone sera disponible
pour l'intérieur de la maison ça
remplace beaucoup de choses en ce sens
comme ma liste d'épicerie banlieue de la
première note je la dis vocalement alexa
alex a ajouté chips sur liste d'achats
les appareils d'amazon enregistre et
transmettent une foule d'informations
vous concernant dans les serveurs de
l'entreprise
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils ramassent dans
les lots
c'est dans le but de vendre quelque
chose c'est
c'est vraiment le but principal
l'objectif pour amazon cédait d'une
classe qu'on a ces deux dates à la suite
des données pour anticiper nos besoins
avant que nous mêmes on arrive à lens le
jour où qu'amazon commence déjà à
m'envoyer des produits avant que je suis
au courant cabinet de besoin puis que la
boîte arrive à ma porte ah ben oui c'est
vrai quelle bonne idée ça va d'un
avantage concurrentiel
vraiment fort un tueur du cygne et amusé
en ligne amazon aura bientôt tout un
arsenal de données supplémentaires
le bracelet lots lancées en 2020 va en
savoir beaucoup plus que les autres
moniteur d'activité
sûr que l'on
oublie mitteland d'ingérence au niveau
de la vie privée
le nouveau territoire d'expansion
d'amazon c'est la santé en 2018 elle a
acheté pile pas qu un service de
pharmacie en ligne et depuis peu elle
offre des services de télémédecine le
risque pour nous divulguer autant
l'information à une compagnie comme
amazon si le conflit d'intérêts on
pourrait arriver à une étape où d'un
côté on veut nous encourager à manger de
plus de sucre et rip d'un côté on va
nous encourager à consommer plus de
pilules pour traiter le diabète
plusieurs gouvernements à travers le
monde se demande comment faire face à la
croissance galopante d'amazon
la commission européenne a ouvert deux
enquêtes sur les pratiques
potentiellement
anticoncurrentiel de l'entreprise le
bureau canadien de la concurrence mène
aussi sa propre enquête depuis un an et
aux états unis on a recommandé
l'adoption de lois qui pourrait empêcher
amazon d'entrer en concurrence directe
avec ses vendeurs
si cela entraînait une hausse des prix
on pourrait bien voir les consommateurs
se lever pour protéger amazon
c'est sûr que ça prend une volonté
politique vraiment très forte pour aller
à l'encontre du bien du consommateur son
père soit qu' une loi voire neobe c'est
le pouvoir d'achat c'est sûr qu'elle
politiquement ça près de vue comme un
suicide
amazon a refusé de nous accorder une
entrevue à la caméra par courriel au
sujet de la concurrence directe entre
amazon et ses vendeurs elle nous a écrit
notre engagement envers nos partenaires
et plus ferme que jamais nous
travaillons fort pour les aider à
réussir
au sujet des suspensions de compte elle
ajoute nous travaillons fort pour
prévenir toute application erronée des
politiques nous veillons à ce que les
vendeurs disposent de délais suffisants
pour les demandes de documentation
pour ce qui est des retours abusif vous
vous souvenez de l'expérience que nous
avons tenté avec les mocassins de
jonathan amazon écrit nous prenons les
mesures nécessaires dans les rares cas
où les clients font un usage abusif de
notre politique de retour mais dans les
faits jonathan je vous dois de l'argent
mais voilà en fait je vous dois 83
dollars et
22 sous parce que j'ai acheté cette
jolie paire de mocassins et j'y
retournais cette vieille pas de
mocassins payées 2 dollars et j'étais
complètement remboursé par amazon co
vrais pauvres est tellement volumes
élevés sur amazon qui contrôlent pas
depuis neuf semaines 10% seulement des
700 paire de mocassins que jonathan a
envoyé chez amazon ont été vendus genre
mais ça ça aille plus vite
mais on se rend compte qu amazon c'est
une plateforme sur laquelle c'est
difficile de se démarquer pour une
marque nouvelle comme nous mais on
travaille dessus puis on voit une
progression jonathan est convaincu qu'à
long terme amazon aura un impact positif
sur sa compagnie il n'a pas perdu espoir
juste un peu de naïveté moi en tant que
vendeur d'amazon je suis juste un
morceau du puzzle qui sert à amazon
allende à son client directement c'est
le client d'abord et avant tout
[Musique]